i'm afraid i have to play this as much
as it pains me ben shapiro
is back on the college circuit again
doing yaf events which is great
but during the q a event um
one of our courageous brothers one of
our comrades from the sweet baby gang
was generous enough
this was an act of generosity and we in
the sweet baby gang are very generous
and so he was generous enough to offer
ben an opportunity to pledge his undying
loyalty to the gang
and ben was uh i have to say
not gracious in his response listen
one more question
[Applause]
would i be able to get you right here
right now to pledge your undying
allegiance to matt walsh's sweet baby
gang
[Music]
no okay
reprehensible
not even worthy of an explanation
says bench let's be honest about what
this is gang
uh ben
shapiro has declared war
on the sweet baby gang
and because
anyone who does not swear fealty to the
sweet baby gang is our enemy we all
understand that
you're either in the gang or you're not
and if you're not then you're an enemy
and an existential threat to our
existence
that's the side that uh ben shapiro has
chosen and he will rue the day
rue the day
next time i see him here in the office
i'm gonna
i'm not gonna say anything but i will
think you have no idea the kinds of
things i'll be thinking
although i do when i listen to that clip
i did like the fact that uh he mentioned
the sweet baby gang and the crowd you
know i was kind of expecting the crowd
just there to be a confused silence in
the crowd what
but no the sweep this this is the this
is how fast the sweet baby gang has
grown this is how our movement is
growing
everyone in that crowd knew exactly they
were all members of the gang
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated